starlink launch webcast my name is
Zachary Lupine and I'll be your host for
today's starlink Mission which marks
spacex's 45th launch of the year and
244th overall mission to date the Falcon
9 rocket which you can kind of see on
your screen through the Marine layer is
currently at Vandenberg space force
base's space launch complex 4 East in
California awaiting liftoff at 12 29 PM
Pacific time
at T-minus 4 minutes and 40 seconds the
weather is green and the range is ready
to support teams are currently tracking
no issues with the vehicle or the
spacecraft
coming up shortly we should see the
clamp arms on the strong back opening up
those clamp arms are located just below
the payload fairing
and it might not be totally visible
visible because of that Marine layer
the strong back or transporter erector
is the truss structure next to the
rocket that is used for rollout and a
route propellants and electrical power
to the vehicle in preparation for launch
and you can just make out the strong
back retracting on your screen there now
coming up next at T minus three minutes
we should hear that stage one has
completed liquid oxygen loading
stage one lock float is complete
at T minus three minutes the Falcon 9
first stage is fully loaded with rocket
propellant 1 or rp1 and liquid oxygen or
locks and we're awaiting completion of
locks load on the second stage in about
45 seconds from now
now aside from the Marine layer you may
also see some white clouds around the
vehicle those white clouds are chilled
gas above the Lox tank liquid surface
that we vent overport to maintain
pressure in the tank as needed and when
that gas comes out into the California
air the humid moist air condenses into
clouds of water
coming up shortly we should hear a call
out that locks loading is complete on
the second stage
the booster or first stage of the rocket
that you see on your screen is flying
for its 12th time today
after liftoff
after liftoff and Stage separation this
booster is scheduled to land on our
drone ship of course I still love you
which is currently stationed in the
Pacific Ocean
as many of you lock slow is complete and
there's that call out that stage two
locks loading is complete Falcon 9 is
now fully loaded with 1 million pounds
of fuel and liquid oxygen
now as many of you may already know
successfully recovering parts of our
Rockets allow SpaceX to refly the most
expensive pieces which in turn drives
down the cost of space access
coming up in about 10 seconds from now
we should hear a call out that Falcon 9
is in startup which means the flight
computers have taken over the launch
countdown
Falcon 9 is in startup
and there's that call out that Falcon 9
is in startup in a few seconds we should
hear our launch director or LD give the
final go for launch
LDS go for launch
and there's that go from the launch
director to proceed with today's Mission
so let's sit back and watch as Falcon 9
takes our 48 Starling satellites into
space
T-minus 30 seconds
15 seconds
T-minus ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one engines whole power
and liftoff of Starling 513 go falcon go
starlink
foreign
chamber pressures are nominal
that's a fuel tank
at t plus 30 seconds Falcon 9 has
successfully lifted off from slick 4
East from Vandenberg space force base in
California at 1229 Pacific PM Pacific
Time now the next major Milestone coming
up is Max Q which is when the vehicle
experiences that were in Telemetry
nominal which is when the vehicle
experiences the greatest amount of
external stresses as it descends through
the Earth's atmosphere
Falcon 9 is supersonic
and there's that call out that Falcon 9
is supersonic which means that the
rocket is traveling faster than the
speed of sound we should hear that call
out for Max Q shortly
and there's that call out for Max Q
which again is when the rocket
experiences the largest amount of
external stresses
now we are just about one minute away
from a series of events main engine
cutoff stage separation second engine
start one and then lastly fairing
separation Mikko or main engine cutoff
is where all nine of the Merlin 1D
engines on the first stage shut down
that's followed by stage separation when
the first and second stages separate
scs-1 or second engine start one is
where we light the Merlin vacuum engine
on the second stage and lastly fairing
separation is when the two fairing
halves separate and fall away from the
second stage so let's keep an eye out
for those events which will happen in
quick succession
oh
Mikko stage separation confirmed
and back ignition
and as you just saw and heard over the
Nets we had successful Mikko stage step
and ses1 separation confirmed
and there's that confirmation of faring
separation from the second stage we will
be attempting to recover both praying
halves using our recovery vessel go
beyond
both of the fairing halves that
supported today's Mission are flight
proven with one half flying for its
fourth time and the other half flying
for its seventh time
on the left side of your screen right
now is our Falcon 9 first stage and on
the right side is the mvac engine on our
second stage currently carrying the
starlink satellites to orbit
currently the first stage is on its way
back to Earth towards our drone ship of
course I still love you which is located
in the Pacific Ocean
the mbac engine attached to the second
stage is continuing its burn which will
last about another four and a half
minutes
as a reminder starlink is a satellite
internet constellation designed and
manufactured by SpaceX to provide high
speed low latency internet to people
living in remote and Rural locations
around the globe
directory
and as I mentioned earlier today's
starlink Mission Mark spacex's 244th
Mission overall and the 45th Mission
just this year coming up next in the
mission is the entry burn on the first
stage which is the first of two Burns it
will go through in preparation for
landing
we should see that stage one entry Burns
start in just under a minute from now
stage one entry burnt startup
and there's that call out for the stage
one entry burn which you can see on the
left side of your screen there vehicles
on a nominal trajectory
stage one which we also call the booster
has ignited three engines to slow it
down four atmospheric re-entry
stage one entry burn shutdown
and there's that call out that the entry
burn on the first stage has completed
coming up next is the landing burn on
the first stage which is the second and
final burn in preparation for landing
stage one FTS has saved
stage one transonic
and there's that call out that the first
stage is transonic which means it is
traveling near the speed of sound
coming up in about 20 seconds from now
we should see the stage one Landing burn
start on the left side of your screen
stage two internal guidance
oh look at that stage one Landing burn
and there's confirmation that the stage
one Landing burn has started in
preparation for touchdown on our drone
ship of course I still love you in the
Pacific Ocean we should also hear that
call out for Seco or second engine
cutoff
stage one Landing light deploy
stage one Landing in front
and if you can hear that cheering
everyone here at Hawthorne is very
excited that this Falcon 9 first stage
has now successfully launched and landed
for its 12th time
we also heard that call out for Seco one
and there's confirmation of good orbit
today's Landing marks are 205th overall
Landing of an orbital class rocket
including Falcon 9 and Falcon heavy
missions and with confirmation of
successful first stage landing and
second engine cutoff and orbital
insertion that wraps up our coverage for
now so be sure to check our social media
for confirmation of starlink satellite
deployment thanks for watching and we'll
see you again soon
foreign
[Music]